es un símbolo de los graves problemas de
sequía en el oeste de eeuu por primera
vez la agencia encargada de los recursos
del agua declaró una escasez en el lago
med el mayor reservorio hídrico del país
personas nunca hubo una declaración de
escasez así que el hecho de que estemos
asistiendo a la primera declaración es
bastante significativo históricamente la
escasez provocará cortes del suministro
de agua y restringir a su uso para la
agricultura a partir de octubre los
agricultores ya se están preparando
estaremos perdiendo alrededor de la
mitad de nuestra agua para usar el
próximo año así que vamos a tener que
recortar hectáreas de la producción que
tenemos ahora los niveles de agua del
reservorio han estado bajando durante
años una de las consecuencias del ciclo
de sequía que afecta a la región
byrs y estamos viendo los efectos del
cambio climático a través de la cuenca
del río colorado a través de sequías
prolongadas y temperaturas extremas
incendios forestales expansivos y en
algunos lugares inundaciones y
deslizamientos de tierra
es uno de los reservorios artificiales
que almacenan el agua de río colorado
este embalse abastece a siete estados
estadounidenses y partes de méxico según
un estudio de la agencia geológica de
eeuu el flujo de río colorado ha
disminuido en un promedio del 20 por
ciento durante el siglo pasado una
disminución que no sólo afecta al lago
med sino a todas las fuentes de agua del
oeste de eeuu incluido el lago power la
segunda reserva del país